p-f-t-o-t tuesday edition all the things
we couldn't cram into pft live or things
we would like to expand upon and i think
every topic today is something we
weren't able to get to that's how busy
of a day it's been let's begin in
buffalo chris news emerged during the
program that veteran defensive end jerry
hughes signing a two-year extension he
was entering the final year of his
contract adam schafter of espn reports
that it's worth up to 23.5 million with
19 million guaranteed which is a weird
split it's because the base value is
going to be less than 23 and a half
million and if
19 million guaranteed it's just it's
just an i i'll wait to see the full
contract to come to any conclusions
about what it's really worth but i'm
surprised the bills did this because
hughes was the guy who was almost traded
to the rams last year the rams tried to
get hughes before they moved on to dante
fowler i just assumed hughes would
finish out his contract this year in
buffalo and move on yeah i did too i
guess they looked at it too though
there's no legitimate edge threat on
that defense there in buffalo either so
i think they looked at it and go okay
he's really the only proven commodity we
have at that position you know they got
guys like trent murphy and mackenzie
alexander who've had years of
lorenzo alexander excuse me we've had
years of you know putting up some decent
sack numbers but you know hey it's a 4-3
defense he still has speed and there's a
threat to come around the edge and and
of course be a nuisance at the
quarterback so uh i get it i guess i'm a
little surprised by the contract details
too but it's early and i don't think we
know all the facts of the situation uh
yet either
started his career with the bills with
the colts rather became a full-time
starter in buffalo in 2014 and has not
missed a game
in five full seasons uh
yes five full seasons as a starting
defensive lineman for the buffalo bill
so jerry hughes clearly sticking around
we'll see what the actual contract
details are you know what happens a lot
of times and look anybody who pays
attention to the sport knows this the
agent puts out
numbers that look better than maybe they
are to make the agent look better so the
agent can then use that to try to
recruit other clients it's a very common
game and the reporters will pass along
because they're just happy to have the
information even if the numbers are
embellished we'll see what the real
numbers are but hughes sticking around
he'll be under contract for three years
in buffalo yannick and gawkway would
very much like to have his second
contract with the jacksonville jaguars
he had been boycotting the off-season
program but he reportedly is going to be
present for otas this is a guy who's
going to make 2 million this year he's a
guy who has a ton of sacks in three nfl
seasons and we're seeing how much guys
get paid
i'm surprised he's putting himself at
risk here chris when you're drawing that
line in the sand to try to get your big
contract don't show up for things that
aren't mandatory i i'm a little
surprised too i mean again yannick ague
he's in the conversation for one of the
best better pass rushers in all of
football i mean i'm not gonna i think
put him up there towards the top of the
list but he's not far off from it from
there i mean uh he's he's incredible get
off the line of scrimmage the ability to
bend around the line of scrimmage i mean
i would think he's a guy that's going to
be looking at some type of contract
that's in the 18 million dollars a year
range now showing up for otas the first
thing i always think about is just okay
what are we going to be doing at otas
he's going to show up yeah we'll you
know will he have a conversation with
some of the people uh tom coughlin some
of the people in the front office to
maybe gauge how he wants to practice
those are the things that
at least are going through my mind
because he might just partake in some
individual drills uh maybe not to
partake in some of the full team
activities that put himself in more
danger that certainly could be a
possibility he might just be there for
meetings and work out jacksonville might
be happy with that if they have the
right conversation so i guess i i want
to see more of what it entails first and
is it really a full go at practice
and that's a good point he could be
there but he could be staying away from
the kinds of activities that would get
him potentially injured i don't know
that tom coughlin the executive vp of
football operations would be comfortable
with that approach because his attitude
probably is you're all in or you're all
out yeah but in gawkway and look he he
has been great chris over the last three
seasons demarcus lawrence 25 and a half
sacks joey bosa 28 and a half sacks
yannick and
a half sacks now bose has been injured a
lot right but still he's got more than
bowser he's got more than lawrence and
frank clark has 32 only two and a half
more than yannick and gagwe and we saw
what frank clark got paid so so uh and
gakui deserves to get paid and this is
all in how you play just right right and
you know what it may be you've you've
got to play out this season and get
franchise tagged or hit the open market
next year uh because sometimes the team
is going to take full advantage of that
cheaper contract and force you to finish
it even though you are carrying some
significant injury that's going to be
interesting jalen ramsey i mean he's
coming up to bat you know so they got
some people they have to pay miles jack
is going to be in this conversation so
someone might get left out in the dark
there in jacksonville and that that's to
me where it's going to be you know
fascinating going forward because
they're they like you said i mean this
is a guy that's you know in the
conversation for top pass rushers in
football they can't pay everybody uh and
also you have to take into account man
they got a first round defensive lineman
from last year from florida of course
they have clayus campbell so you have to
look at all those factors too and go
okay yannick and gawkway's awesome don't
get me wrong but he's benefited from
having some awesome players around him
too to always give him favorable
matchups
and what did we see happen twice this
year the tag and trade of pass rush d
ford from the chiefs to the 49ers frank
clark from the seahawks to the chiefs
maybe the jaguars play here is
tag him
and then trade him because again you
can't keep everyone you have to trust
your ability to scout rookies and
younger players and they'll step in and
step up and
it it's you could make the argument it's
a hell of a lot smarter to tag and trade
well it is a hell of a lot smarter to
tag and trade if you can pull it off
than to let a guy leaving free agency
and get a compensatory draft pick you
get more if you can trade him from under
the franchise tag right malcolm jenkins
a veteran member of the eagles secondary
he was a first-round pick 10 years ago
of the saints he is not present for otas
in philly he hasn't been present for the
off-season program howard eskin the
sideline reporter for the eagles radio
network says it is a contractual issue
for malcolm jenkins it's surprising a
lot of people but jenkins doing what he
has to do to take a stand for himself
and get paid and for guys under contract
the one thing you can do chris withhold
services and when you withhold services
from voluntary workouts that gets
people's attention because most of the
players show up yeah it definitely does
and especially with a guy like malcolm
jenkins who's such a you know key piece
to that defense in general i mean he's a
great communicator a great player does a
lot of different things uh for that
defense schematically one of the leaders
in the locker room i think we've seen
that so yeah he's unhappy with where
he's being paid at as far as his worth
and i get that he probably looks at it
and goes there's some guys hey he looks
at earl thomas uh who's making 13.7
million dollars and he goes wait that's
not right he's making five million
dollars more than i am that so i
understand it the market has moved once
again at the safety position and i think
he looks at some players that are above
him and making more money than he goes
they're not as good as me they don't
deserve to be making that money and he
wants a little sweetener
yeah and and uh he's due to make i had
the numbers right here 8.1 million in
base salary this year and 7.6 million
next year and earl thomas really did put
a foot to the ass of the safety market
after last year when it languished i
think his teams were trying to justify
not signing eric reid but eric reed got
paid this year by the panthers earl
thomas got paid tyron matthew got paid
and malcolm jenkins doing what he can to
get his money before maybe he's too old
to get the kind of contract he's looking
that's right all right another guy not
present at ota is chris but this has
nothing to do with contract he's gotten
his contract and he was smart to do it
when he did rams running back todd
gurley not there now the team says he's
got an arrangement where he's working
out on his own and etc but with that
knee you know anytime todd gurley isn't
present and accounted for and practicing
people are gonna wonder what's up with
that knee and until we see a healthy
todd gurley play on multiple weeks it's
not just gonna be one game for me it's
not just gonna be week one he has 180
yards from scrimmage and everything's
fine he's got to show me he can come
back again and again and again and even
then i'm gonna wonder are we gonna have
the same thing that happened last
december where all of a sudden the knees
just shot for the year and that's my
concern with todd gurley so when you see
todd gurley not at otas
i i think you have to say
where is this all heading and will he
ever be the guy that he used to be yeah
i mean i'm concerned a little bit i'm
not gonna lie uh again i know it's otas
so it's not end-all be-all here but this
is one of the star premier players for
the los angeles rams franchise uh and of
course they're paying them a hefty sum
so when i hear things like that hey i
understand like superstar players they
do have the leeway to do their own thing
at times uh but i almost think mike and
this is i have no knowledge of this but
just my the thing i think of right away
here is you know maybe the rams are
happy with keeping them away you know
because maybe he is not a hundred
percent uh and they don't want the media
to sit there and see that you know maybe
his knee is swollen or not quite the way
it should be or he can't participate so
they'd rather not have him there and
continue to work with the guy he's got
to work with or feels comfortable with
to get this knee and leg issue straight
those are the things i think of going
forward i'm not concerned that he's
missing this there's nothing that he's
missing that's going to
dictate how he plays in 2019
but i do wonder about how much is
how much of this is about management of
the knee and that issue there
and to the extent that he is dealing
with management of pain there may
eventually be some good news for todd
gurley and the rest of the nfl players
who are always dealing with pain issues
when you consider what they do for a
living the nfl and the nfl players
association announced on monday an
agreement to form a committee that will
study alternate therapies for management
of pain including chris
marijuana yeah for the first time the
nfl
acknowledging that maybe this is a good
idea you know stepping away from the
collectively bargained right to tell
players thou shalt not smoke weed and to
suspend them for years at a time if they
do
the nfl recognizing maybe it's in the
best interest of the sport to find a way
to back off from this prohibition on the
use of marijuana and basically give the
players who needed a medical card and
really
what the threshold would have to be very
low to have the pain necessary to use
marijuana because they're all in pain
throughout the course of the season
right the threshold's very low to get
opioids i know that and man they're a
whole lot more dangerous for your body
than certainly smoking marijuana is and
uh again yes i think the the nfl should
exhaust all avenues as far as finding
better ways to help players deal with
pain management and healing their body
uh hey we've heard guys like brett favre
who had the opioid addictions when he's
playing i know i had some teammates that
you know dealt with issues there as far
as getting off the addiction pattern and
all that of of pills that they had
become accustomed to popping uh through
the end of their career because they
were trying to just make it happen on a
daily basis and just wanted to get
through that day so oh let me pop a
vicodin let me pop an anti-inflammatory
let me pop this now that the day's over
and yeah it not only just ruins your
body it ruins your stomach uh it messes
with the chemistry of your brain and hey
one why bite off the nose despite the
phase two i mean we miss a key important
players in the nfl every year over guys
that i know have broken the rules uh of
what they are in the nfl but you know
again if alcohol is going to be legal
then i don't see how we can argue that
marijuana is not legal at this point and
i'm glad that the nfl seems like they're
going in the right direction and chris
i've noticed over the past year the nfl
has softened in its application of the
rules two guys like josh gordon martavis
randy gregory even though all three are
currently suspended
they had multiple incidents while
returning from a minimum suspension of a
year still in stage three where
supposedly one falls move gets you
suspended for another year minimum the
nfl has been working with these guys
because i think the nfl understands
what's going on here and i think finally
someone at 345 park avenue developed a
sense of self-awareness on this issue
instead of trying to cram something down
the union's throat where you get a
concession for a retreat on the
marijuana prohibition just realize it's
the right thing to do yeah it's smart
for everybody let's come up with a way
to do it but you know chris there's one
wrinkle left here that could get a
little awkward there are several states
where the nfl currently does business
texas tennessee georgia north carolina
indiana and wisconsin that still have a
complete ban on marijuana use yeah what
do you do to get your players in a
position where they can use medical
marijuana in states where it's still
illegal yeah that's tricky i mean the
first thing i want to say with those
states is get a clue get up with the
times let's go let's
okay i mean there's other things that
are legal in those states where i want
to go whoa that's legal but damn you
know
smoking something that's going to put
you on the couch and make you eat a bag
of chips whoa we can't let that be legal
uh so yeah again that that is going to
be the million-dollar question right
mike how does the nfl really
realistically navigate through that
issue i mean i ask you mr lawyer can you
really
do that i mean how would they do it
first of all and i don't know if this is
a product of the marijuana it's 2019 not
2018. but but even more reason to get
with the times
i think what they need to do is they
need to aggressively lobby in those
states and they need to already start or
if they haven't started they should
start now
trying to lay the foundation to get
medical marijuana authorization in place
in those states now it's not like you're
going to dangle relocation because what
the texans or the cowboys are going to
move the packers are gonna move right
nobody's moving over it but let me tell
you if it would be a strange state of
affairs if you had the ability on every
other team to smoke marijuana yeah right
the cowboys texans colts titans panthers
falcons packers are out in the cold good
luck signing free agents
if that's the case you're right exactly
right there's going to be guys who go oh
okay what the cowboys or you know uh
some team in california okay i might
choose california if all things are
equal there the money's pretty much the
same you're right that's going to be a
detractor there but hey we've heard some
stand-up individuals that have played in
the nfl uh you know kind of talk about
marijuana and cbd oil in a glowing way
that i think we have to take into an
account that it really uh that helps
people i know i got ex-friends uh who
believe in cbd oil and smoking you know
marijuana to help with their aches and
pains we heard a guy like calvin johnson
who i don't believe has ever been in any
shape form or even close to trouble in
his whole life he's talking about it how
it's helping his body so uh i think it
just makes too much sense you know to
find another way to help some of these
players out who are getting beat to crap
during the season
and you know people ask me all the time
you hate the nfl you criticize the nfl
it's like i love the nfl i want the nfl
to be as good as it can be and we try to
highlight areas where we think the nfl
could be better and the fact that the
nfl has found a way to just start down
this path of doing the right thing the
nfl deserves to be applauded because for
a long time the nfl dug in and i
remember when states first started to
legalize it for recreational purposes
the nfl said well it's still
illegal under federal law and they were
going to cling to that until the federal
government drops its prohibition on
marijuana use good to see that the nfl
realizes there's benefit there to the
players chris and it's the right thing
to do yes and last thing because this is
something that's been kind of like
annoying me you know
we talk about marijuana and we talk
about oh a federal law and it's not
legal there you know what okay i get
that and i'm not trying to even defend
that what drives me crazy is federal law
never gets brought up with um with with
ped little use that to me is one thing
that annoys me as far as substance abuse
in the nfl and ped use we go oh gosh
that guy was just cheating trying to
make his muscles bigger like a patrick
peterson but we never forget that a lot
of the times they're taking substances
that are illegal in our country too they
have broken the law let alone tried to
cheat us and showing us that they're not
the talent that they are trying to claim
they are because they're chemically
enhanced uh i don't know why i'm saying
that it just bothers me at times because
federal law gets associated with
marijuana but then guys cheat and set
bad examples for young kids and do it
illegally and nobody talks about the
federal law with that so sorry i just
had to get that off my chest no that's
good and it's it's smart and it's smart
that the nfl
is finally
acknowledging that there's benefit here
to the players that marijuana is safer
than opioid use and let's drop this this
uh big brother routine where they want
to police and legislate what guys do in
the off season right seven months
they're left to their own devices it was
it was dumb in the first place i
understand why they did it was it was a
reflection of the times and the war on
drugs and all that stuff and it was a pr
thing but now it's times have changed
and it's time for the nfl to change and
we're going to sit at the door chris
great stuff as always
you're off wednesday you're on
assignment wednesday
is it secret what you're doing well i
don't know if it was it's not secret now
i've said it so we'll just keep going
will you will you take a picture of
yourself wearing sonora's perry's number
32 o.j simpson jersey absolutely not i
won't do that you can't do it all right
uh well enjoy buffalo on wednesday and
we'll see you back here on thursday
everybody have a great day chris sims on
button debuts later today there may or
may not be another pft pm today who
knows there was one from yesterday if uh
if you're really anxious to hear more of
me prattling on about a bunch of inane
issues uh pro football talk live though
tomorrow morning 6 a.m eastern nbc
sports radio 7 a.m eastern on nbcsn
everybody have a great day see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports